President Trump and Pope Francis are
meeting for the first time today May
23rd 2017 at the Vatican and as the
media tries to guess what they're going
to say to each other behind closed doors
the real question that I have is what is
hidden in the Vatican secret archives I
mean come on
53 miles of shelf space that has limited
access and you can't just even the
researchers that are allowed in and I'll
get into the details of that in just a
second those that are allowed in are
just they're not allowed to go browsing
they're only allowed to see the
information that they've requested and
when you have 53 miles of shelf space
one can only imagine what they really
have hidden in there so who is actually
allowed within the Vatican secret
archives well-qualified scholars from
institutions of higher education
pursuing scientific research with an
adequate knowledge of archival research
which I mean that's ridiculous who in
the world you know has frickin
experience in archival research anymore
that's silly may apply for an entry card
scholars need an introductory letter by
either a recognized Institute of
research or by a suitably qualified
person in the field of historical
research applicants need to specify
their personal name and information as
well as the purpose of their research
undergraduate students are not admitted
there are strict limitations to what
archive users are able to view an access
for example no materials dated after
1939 are available for public viewing
which is interesting by the way because
that's the precise year that World War
two started which I'll mention later in
the video now there are 53 miles or 85
kilometers of shelf space in the library
and you must have a specific request to
pursue that specific subject there is no
browsing permitted whatsoever instead
researchers request specific documents
using bulky catalogs which are usually
handwritten in Italian or Latin and they
can only request up to three folders
each day if within just a few minutes
they realize that the information that
they're seeking is not in the requested
folders their first to pack up for the
day which is incredibly inconvenient and
challenging for researchers and scholars
because
them are traveling incredibly long
distances just to visit the Vatican
secret archives no photographs are
permitted whatsoever however laptops are
okay as long as they're only utilized
for note-taking so just to clarify
there's no browsing whatsoever so you're
only allowed to research what you know
already exists so anything else in there
that well may not be known to the public
is not accessible whatsoever I mean come
on is that shady or what and the fact
that you can only request three folders
per day with even if it in a couple
minutes you realize like oh I have the
wrong folder I need the next one over oh
sorry you have to leave for the day and
request a new one that's stupid and tell
me that's not indicative of hiding
something of something Shady
I mean think about that where to be
hiding in there we're talking 53 miles
of shelf space like if I said five miles
of shelf space you'd be like oh wow
that's a lot 53 miles and you can only
request what you know exists give me a
break
now there's tons of speculation of what
they're hiding in there whether it's
information about tying the Vatican to
Nazi Germany because there's some shady
stuff there by the way I mean come on
you can't visit or view anything in the
archives after 1939 the precise year the
World War two starts and there's already
tons of evidence that ties various
funding as well as the Vatican you know
obviously vit at that I have a lot of
questions all I know is I don't have all
the answers but many speculate that it
might be some answer is related to World
War two within the archives there's also
a ton of speculation as to what happened
to the fourteen missing chapters within
the Bible apparently I mean if you're
not aware the Vatican the Roman Catholic
Church absolutely altered the Bible so
did the King J sort of King James the
King James Version is altered and so the
question becomes well what's original
what isn't and well does Jesus as an
example did he was he able to write
because many theorize that he was able
to but he was not able to lead the
masses in such a way without being
educated I mean many people have
theorized on this it's a big controversy
obviously but clearly there's something
within the archives now other people
have stated that it might involve aliens
that it might involve things with you
know corruption and pornography even
there's all kinds of speculations I
don't know what's in there all I know
that they're hiding something and it's
beyond obvious why would they go to such
incredible and difficult lengths for
people to research this stuff and make
anything that's unknown well unknowable
think about that guys a religion with
secrets isn't a religion it's a control
mechanism I mean let me give you an
example I used to go to Sunday School
for years and I went to church every
Sunday with my family growing up how
many Catholics have ever heard of the
pineal gland or the pinecone statue
within the Vatican I was never taught of
this in Sunday school or ever heard
about it in church not once ever neither
does anyone else I know that's Catholic
yet the pineal gland which is the shape
of a pinecone is utilized through
ancient cultures around the world dating
back thousands of years whether it's the
Egyptians with the Eye of Horus or even
the Sumerians or even Buddhist statues
containing the the pinecone and this
goes back to even other places as well
as you can see here I mean besides the
fact that the Vatican has an 11 foot
solid bronze statue that is 2,000 years
old which is pretty unexplainable they
say it used to be a fountain and it's
really mysterious yet the Pope and many
Popes have carry around a staff that has
a pinecone on it I mean when you have
the Egyptians making a big deal about
this as well as the Sumerians and by the
way the Sumerians are allegedly the
birthplace of civilization I mean most
of mathematics dates back to the
Sumerians our modern calendar as well as
the first documented language ever
written dates back to the Sumerians as
well and somehow the Sumerians knew
thousands of years before this first
telescope about detailed information
about the planets orbiting our Sun such
as that the Jupiter was bigger than
Saturn and Mars smaller than Earth and
so on and so on they somehow had this
information and the Sumerians just so
happened to make a very big deal of the
pineal gland you know that reminds me
why did the Vatican establish a
telescope that's right the Vatican has
their own telescope it's located in on
the other side of the world in Arizona
on mountain Graham you can look into
this it's called the Vatican advanced
technology telescope and elbow I've
tried extensively to figure out what
made them want to build this in the
first place I can never get a straight
answer it to be honest is kind of
mysterious I would like to hear
first-hand from the Pope why they have
this frickin telescope now as you see
this picture here of the Pope you see
the obelisk in the
background this is of course located at
the Vatican and as you are aware obelisk
you can find them in ancient Egypt and
it just so happens I mean look at the
inscription here
the Egyptians each tin stone the seeing
eye the Eye of Horus the same thing
that's based off the pan yo gland and
the pinecone statue and we also see
obelisks of course in Washington DC as
well as in New York Paris London and
don't forget of the symbolism here I
mean look at the as above so below
symbolism when it comes to the
Washington Monument water feature or
even the pyramid as well as the eye on
the back of the one dollar bill I mean
is this all just a coincidence I mean
when you have numerous cultures eating
back thousands of years discussing in
depth about the intuitive abilities of
people that stem from the pineal gland
which is the shape of a pinecone it's
time for people to start asking new
questions and start challenging the
Vatican to open up the Vatican archives
it is literally a crime against humanity
to have a religious faith withholding
information and some sort of
documentation dating back thousands of
years
that of course is applicable to ancient
human civilization and these connections
that you've seen in this presentation
clearly show well that the powers that
be clearly knows something that the
masses do not anyways guys are going to
close up there well I can subscribe
leave me a comment let me know what your
thoughts are I know this is a touchy
subject because it's religion but
ultimately only the truth will set us
free
I'm Jimmy this bright insight take care
everybody